check it out in five four I don't even
[ __ ] use the right hand I said five I
use the one I copied you
you're stupid dude no [ __ ] don't you
have a young daughter that you have to
teach numbers to I'm younger than okay
in five four City it's a tool it's a
line what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast I'm your host David so and we
have a very special guest here today now
you've seen her in a lot of my videos
just because this [ __ ] is insane in and
if you guys notice if you're watching
this on the video platform yeah we got a
new setup
I know I love this place I just already
said I love your colors I'm pretty good
you know I really like about the whole
podcast space like I know that there is
a video section but I don't really dress
up I keep it mad casual yeah
no I came in because we have to be you
have to be good yeah you gotta be
comfortable
exactly what you've been up to [ __ ]
there's so much that you've been up to
really you know what like I have
recently been running into people named
insane you know what though I have only
because I am a mother too so even might
I have my downtime I still you know
Instagram stuff like that social media
wise and I'm always doing something
whether being a mother or courier yeah
you know what's interesting like I
really wanted to bring you on this
podcast cuz I wanted to talk to you
about something I'm not sure if you're
ready to open up and talk about this I'm
scared but the reason why is because
like I like bringing my friends in here
to talk about their [ __ ] just because
like you you're a very interesting
upbringing and I want to talk to you
about this [ __ ] too just because like yo
don't take this don't take this the
wrong ways or nothing's you know I'm
saying okay okay what is it
I might [ __ ] person do it no you're not
a [ __ ] pretty if you worship person I
would have never invited you over to my
house like oh [ __ ] you're right Mikasa
yeah like we've been I've been noticing
as I get older um specifically a lot of
it has to do with relationships yes and
specifically what I've noticed like like
you you have you your dad has been
missing in your life when you were
younger and
a lot of female friends who've had like
their male figure gone and what I've
noticed about a lot of the girls in my
life like you and a few my other friends
who actually have come on this podcast
and talked about this like having that
stable household it's it's it seems to
be like a huge precursor to what you see
as a healthy relationship as you're
older yes you're absolutely right and
absolutely I'm sorry okay but you know
what as I'm getting older and because I
when I was pregnant with Kia I was so
afraid you know I wasn't ready I I was
just not ready to be a mother or even
pregnant you know yeah but that's when I
when I realized like okay this is
happening I started really seeking
people like through my friends and stuff
and just talking to them asking them
about their upbringing the way they
think and the way they are and I really
realized that my sociology class was
completely 1,000 [ __ ] percent right
like the first five years of a child's
life is so detrimental like it's so
important to their life because you know
if it if it if it was just the first
five years I'm talking about like the
way that they are cared for their
education their household environment
everything because were you growing up
you you didn't have a dad figure I
growing up growing up I didn't I didn't
grow up with the father but I grew up
with several male figures as my father
yeah and I'll be completely honest you
know I've been through a lot of domestic
abuse a lot of emotional abuse in terms
of what like the the males in your life
yeah like my mother didn't know cuz she
would she would be the one working you
know she was always a hard worker so
she's always out the house working so
she didn't know till I would tell her I
had the courage to tell her but you know
I grew up in Oakland I grew up in it's
in San Cisco with male figures who were
supposed to be my
father but you know I would like yeah
people get their ass whipped but this
was like on me like for I'm gonna be
really honest on your podcast I'm very
honest person but you know someone
hasn't really asked me in this dist EPS
I guess I'm on a podcast but you know at
the age of four or five I was being
choked against the what the [ __ ] yeah
who by my stepfather at the time get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah and well your mom
didn't know that no cuz she would be
working and she was she was actually a
beauty school at that time because she
has her own salon but my mother wasn't
there because she had to do what she had
to do but that man that was my first
male figure I mmm the first male figure
was living in Oakland and what would be
his reason for it what did you do that
would incite his not that it was your
fault or anything but what would like
trigger that for him too so you choke
you see the thing is I can't remember
and in in betweens but I just remember I
was so so lonely in that house because
it was just me my older sister was
living in LA
Oh what the [ __ ] yeah we're separated my
sister lived with her grandparents with
our grandparents who just my harmony
turned a hundred whoa oh yeah when I saw
that I was like four we I thought you
were joking
no dude she's 100 and she's [ __ ]
still hilarious and she's been around
before there were cars that were
commercial yes yo your grandma was
reading by it [ __ ] candlelight before
really I was she was reading stones and
[ __ ] on the stone but like ya know my
grandma just turned 100 thank God but um
she my sister lived in my grandparents
in k-town yeah and I moved to Oakland
and you know I wasn't I was just very
lonely I don't I just think he wasn't
ready to be a father you know and I had
to forgive him in my way you know and
realize that he didn't know what he was
doing and maybe I I don't really
remember anything I was doing you know I
was just playing by myself but I just I
just do remember he would choke me
against the wall outs
it would be like the stairs to go into
our part into the apartment and he would
always take me out the house and there's
this wall here that he would always
choke me against and we should things
like that and then my next father figure
just I went to school like bruises and
my principles like let's go back to the
the first guy how long did he stay
around before your mom separated with
him um I think it was only maybe a year
and a half a year year and a half from
what I you know how your mom left you
alone with this guy no no I was four I
think I was about right well you're four
but like even then like she I'm like I
said I don't know your mom yeah you know
if I have a kid I'm not thinking about
leaving my kid with some dude that I
just met oh no no no no they've been
together I think they were dating and I
was just four I don't remember the I
don't know the details I was really
young I was so young but I just no I was
about four and when we when we moved in
with him you know then she went to
beauty school ah that happened with the
same same thing with another guy you
know she didn't know till I had to tell
her but when I was four their
relationship just fell apart regardless
without me saying anything yeah I mean
if he's choking on a little kid I'm
pretty sure he has anger issues and
there's a lot of issues he's after he
has to deal with exactly so I'm pretty
sure that they have issues within their
own relationship but the next father
figure
yeah I would go to school with bruises
and then my I remember my principal
taking me to her office and asking me if
I would like to call the cops because
she saw the bruises on my body and I
don't even know any of this [ __ ] really
no well you didn't tell me about this
stuff I only knew that your I only know
a little bit about your father and not
him not having been around when you were
younger but this best the specificity of
these two guys I had no idea oh damn
this is just crazy
oh man so I'm really spilling my guts to
you guys this is really me this is raw
you know and this is why I I feel for
children that's why I anything I has to
deal with children my heart aches for
and
I I love children and I they are our
future and we as parents and adults have
I do really believe it starts with us
first you know not you know they say
chicken or the egg whatever I really do
believe in this situation it deals with
the parents and us as adults to make
sure we are becoming better humans for
the future you know so this guy that
came around the the second guy that came
around like he would like well he would
hit you with his hand um no not with you
know like those feather duster oh yeah
very Korean is he Korean Chinese a very
Asian of invasion yes yeah but it would
be like this feather stick and I just
remember had a long piece of wood and it
was circular and he would just like go
ham and it once my broke right in the
middle so he taped it with plastic tape
so it hurt like even more you know it
Hewitt it's like one of the discipline
was that I got caught watching Power
Rangers all right so what was wrong with
Power Rangers they were so positive I
wasn't allowed to watch TV what the [ __ ]
is is it with Asian parents and like not
allowing kids to watch TV because you
know what my parents didn't allow me to
watch TV up to a certain extent right
like if it was Power Rangers Power
Rangers was okay though yeah you know
but I wanted to watch the Cindy Margolis
show where titties were out so that's
right they were you know stepping in but
in terms of Power Rangers is mad
positive yeah Power just pretty [ __ ]
tight dude I love I love that show and I
was watching like at that time I like
you know Captain Planet and all that
stuff but it was it was things more like
what I wasn't allowed to do I sneaked in
you know and because what they weren't
allowing you to do was ridiculous and
I'm pretty sure especially with you know
somebody like that especially he's
beating your ass like that I'm pretty
sure he don't want to explain things to
you either oh no David that's such
[ __ ] amazing point you like said I
had a conversation with my friend Jett
what's up Jett and you know he made me
realize like you know parents especially
I don't know if it's just special
Asian parents of parents don't really
tell kids why not to do things they
don't explain it to just say no you know
it's it's it's a generation because I
mean there's that's a very loaded
subject for me just because like number
one there's a lot of things that you
could think about right like number one
it could be the immigrant factor when
you are trying to when you're living
paycheck to paycheck you don't know
what's going on you're stressed the [ __ ]
out you feel like you don't have enough
time of course you just want to beat
their ass and tell them to shut the [ __ ]
up I get it there's also a second part
of that where sometimes parents are just
[ __ ] stupid and they don't want to be
outsmarted by their kid and so when the
kid asks a question something that's you
should be able to answer as an adult or
if you don't know the answers you still
should be able to talk to your kids but
sometimes when young kids ask an adult a
question the adult because they have a
very small mind feel like they're being
challenged know hey it'll be like Oh
for example which kid though yeah what
the kid cuz my for example a Joe you
know Joe yeah Joe does like the other
half this podcast with me he talks about
his experience growing up as a kid he
would ask his dad a question too and he
also has his father also left them when
he was younger too but he was distinctly
remembers him asking his father a
question right so his father would tell
him to do something I don't know the
specifics but it'll be like hey make
sure that you clean this up after this
time and enjoy it ask well why do you
have to clean up after this time and he
hears that is why are you talking back
to me and he would beat his ass but
instead kids are inquisitive they're
fast and if they say well why do you
have to you should be able to do this
point explain there's a well I'm trying
to teach you structure in order this is
gonna be important for you the future so
do it by this time and say thank you
very good point I do also think it comes
with like you said we know we're always
working working working and working so
by the time you get home you just want
to [ __ ] relax right yeah so I'm gonna
share this story with you so I thought I
was pretty pretty [ __ ] clear with
communicating with people I really
thought I was a [ __ ] with that but my
daughter's school schooled me this one
day I realized a lot about myself this
year too so a lot of self reflecting and
self-awareness it's hard but you know
but I'm happy yeah this is one time like
I got two months ago okay I'm sitting on
the couch I'm [ __ ] dead as tired
right and she runs out the
there she was mom what's this right
she's like this and it's like a toilet
bowl cleaner mm-hmm and I was just like
oh my gosh care like put that down
that's so gross it's just like no mom
like what is this and I was like oh my
gosh can I put that away it's so
disgusting put it away
she's like no mom why are you yelling at
me I'm just asking you what this is and
I was like oh my god so right kay I'm
really really sorry about that and
you're very right but I need you to put
that back because it cleans the toilet
and the toilet is where we pee and poop
so it's really dirty so could you please
put that away cuz it's dirty and go wash
your hands she goes okay
[ __ ] runs out and she actually puts
it back washes her hand and she's only
four yeah and that's and that's true
like you know what kids are going to ask
a lot of questions and you know
sometimes to these these adults who have
kids they've never been around kids you
know I grew up at a church I didn't
either I was a pastor for two years I
was wrong kids my whole life so you know
like I was wrong kids all the time they
ask a lot of [ __ ] questions and
they're [ __ ] annoying they're
supposed to be annoying they're in an
ongoing state exactly your sponge they
want to learn everything so sometimes to
like maybe in your case to when you were
at that age and that guy was kicking
your [ __ ] ass I can I can't ask
question I wasn't able to even talk at
that time but I have to say this um for
the parents out there who have
four-year-olds you know what I do I care
look she's really she's really asking me
why why why right and I answer every
single one and then I get to the point
where I'm like how about you okay why
why do you think I keep asking her why
now she just walks away I'm like I win
I'm a child David I don't work in your
[ __ ] face you fart monster yeah you
want you to beat her up and take her
lunch money too
how must you do that I'm just
outsmarting my child that's so sad that
I don't like it I can't wait to have a
kid already figured out that this is
what I'm gonna do I want to make sure
that they're prepared for every
situation possible specifically
kidnapping situations I just did that oh
really
okay because I'm getting Amber
excuse what I'm gonna do right so I'm
gonna head up my homies and then we're
gonna we're gonna go by a van
I want to stuff that [ __ ] full of candy
and then I'm gonna come up to my kid
I'll be like hey little little paperclip
I don't know that don't know the kid's
name yet hey paper clip hey you huh
you want you want this lollipop and the
kid says yes he comes in I'm turning on
the lights it's gonna be me and all of
his uncles and we're a [ __ ] jump our
kid and beat his [ __ ] ass oh my gosh
at the age of four age of three and then
we're gonna take him away and be like
that's what I [ __ ] told you paper
clip all right
paper clip I told you little sister
thumbtack the same thing and thumbtack
you can do this so paper so paper clip
next time somebody comes into a van
situation and you jump in and get that
lollipop expect that [ __ ] up and you
run the [ __ ] away and you say no but you
know what that's smart because right now
I'm getting so much like so many Amber
Alerts and like child abduction I'm
being honest right now today I grab
chaos hand when she's with me and we get
on her knees and we pray for the kid and
really please please protect the kid so
she sees like how like I you know how
devastated I am and and then I sit with
her I look JIT having these
conversations just these past two weeks
being like what are strangers and her
school taught her that they're wolves
bad wolves so she was like bad wolves
I'm like yeah so if they have candy what
do you do it she goes like there it is
there good good [ __ ] but I was now I'm
still testing I was like well if they
have a puppy all right I'm gonna keep
well a puppy bobby's difference at you
anyway you already have one so you
shouldn't give a [ __ ] it's different but
I do yeah but I think that's great
things I think about it's so good you
don't even have a kid yet well I don't
you know it's not even that I don't know
I think I just I grew up in a setting
with a lot of like people you know and
so for me I think I've always just been
kind of inquisitive and you know by the
way too this is all this is just all
talking conjecture I don't have a kid so
I don't know what it's going to be like
this is only what I'm saying in the
hopes that I'll be able to do these
things that I consider right at the
moment because nobody [ __ ] knows how
you're gonna deal with having a kid
unsure you have a kid it's like
everybody who has an opinion about
relationships
this is what they say they go oh let me
tell you about this [ __ ] alright so I
met this girl and this girl has never
had a boyfriend ever
oh no in her life right that's oh okay
you know she was asking about my
situation with my girlfriend and you
know this is during a time when Mara and
I just got together so you know we're
kind of going back and forth we're
arguing a lot we're getting to know each
other and you know in the beginning all
you see after you move past the
lovey-dovey stage you just see a lot of
your differences and those differences
tend to anger you a lot simply because
you're not connecting how you used to
when you first met you know when you was
going through that infatuation yeah oh
honey and so you know I just told her
about an argument that we had and she
goes well then why are you with it if
you guys are fighting and I looked at
her and I was like what do you what
makes sense I was like what do you mean
and she goes well because if I had I was
with somebody and they spoke to me like
that I would just leave them not a
problem
and I laughed in her face right I need
luck with that yeah I looked at laughed
in her face she goes what do you mean I
was like you don't know what you're
talking about she well I don't like it
that you're belittling because I haven't
been in a relationship I was like number
one you could call it belittling that's
fine you're dumb you just said something
really stupid because you're doing about
something with utter confidence when you
have no no absolutely no experience this
is something repetitive that you hear
from a lot of people who have successful
relationships so where are you coming
saying that you know what a healthy
relationship but you never been into one
wrong or bad wrong or good true true
that this is why I don't take any
relationship advice from Emily you know
like I don't and I plus I don't give it
out because okay but even I know but you
know you know we'll get into that later
on in the podcast but you know even for
you just say just because in your mind
you haven't you know found the one or
you haven't had what you call a
traditionally successful relationship
doesn't mean that you don't have
experiences that you can that you took
away from that you can give to somebody
of course but when somebody sits there
and they judge other people about
relationships that they haven't even
experienced they have any experience the
emotion that's you know and it's kind of
like I looked at her and I laugh and she
got upset and she goes well I'm gonna
know what I'm gonna do I was like no you
think you're gonna know what you're
gonna do you're right I thought I knew
everything dude when I before I met
Muriel I thought I wanted a girl who was
completely sweet quiet and just
agreeable all the time I got the
Antichrist
oh my god I got the exact opposite this
woman challenges me all like a [ __ ] yes
hi beautiful
yeah but it also makes me want a 300
kick her in the [ __ ] stomach yeah but
and then hug her hug her you know but I
love her very much and a lot of the
times too and we I've talked about this
on the podcast as the qualities that you
that you really love about a person also
tends to be the same laws that you hate
about them it's like oh this woman she's
so strong yeah well guess what that
straights come by CVS when you're
arguing exactly that's where there's a
fine line between love and hate
seriously oh for sure
you know and even for you like I don't
even know about that whole situation
about you growing up and the the whole
ass-whooping thing though oh it was it
so wait how old were you after the
second relationship ended with that with
when you're 11 11 yeah and that one was
uh I'm not gonna go in deeper with that
one but it you know it's just it did
your mom about that though at eleven it
ended and then she you know I I felt so
I've you know i yeah is the thing is I'm
I I am understanding my mom so much more
right now with being like a single
parent but I do have you know her you
know like I'm whatever
I'm just understanding my mom just way
more on a mother since and having to
grind and hustle so when I was eleven I
did tell her and it was a hard decision
because she she trusted this man as her
significant other especially with their
children and she didn't know what was
going on cuz she was the person who she
she had a beauty shop such that first
chunk about like a little bit of my life
she was going to beauty schools so in
San Francisco's that's when she had her
shop so she was constantly there so I
remember uh I think my sister my sister
and I told her and it was rough for her
she was she went through like a
depressed face but she told him to get
out oh so wait you were the catalyst
that's that that that's awesome so you
know what the
thing is your mom actually took your
side yeah know what she just didn't she
really didn't know about anything I told
her about that guy maybe like a couple
years ago and even with the second
stepfather I didn't tell her about a lot
of things some just couple years ago
like this specific details mm-hm
that's crazy yeah it's just you know
when a human being humans being humans
when you keep a lot of things and you
know I that's why I I thought the world
owed me everything because I kept all
that [ __ ] in and that's what I'm saying
I've been doing a lot of self-awareness
and a lot of self reflecting the past
year because I I have a kid and I want
to be better for her and I don't wanna I
don't want to put any anything I any
hardships that I had to go through on
her cuz that's not fair so I'm really
trying to you know on try to go through
my past of like really owning it owning
emotions and letting it go and even my
real father I met him
you know that job I did for pop stars
yeah yeah I met my father there in
Incheon my real father
well you've never met him before prior
to that I know the last time I saw him
was when I was three
damn a three-four no no I think three
that's one way I was gone but I saw him
briefly for like a week when I was like
seven I think and then I met him after
the show in Incheon last year in
December it's like two different for two
decades you didn't see your biological
father then you've met him in Korea I
met him and I just like saw him and he
looks like a hotter body that means
grandfather yes so from what I remember
when I was really young too that I when
I looked I am I just I just started
bawling cuz it was I I see a grandfather
now oh I didn't you know it was just
weird to see that and for the first time
this year uh like
I had to let go everything cuz of
talking to him in Korea I just realized
you know he was trying to do his best as
who he is right yeah what the person he
is and I had to let that go and I
straight up said you know he you know he
called me and I was like before he hung
up Appa Appa because I used you know
it's weird to call him that anyways
which is dad and I was like sorry yo and
it floored him what made you want to say
that to him I heard God say that I heard
Gaza in my head Oh cry because it was
just like this weird moment right before
oh my god I'm [ __ ] sweating like
right before he was about to hang up I
just heard in my head it's being like
tell your father that you love him and I
felt that in my heart and I was like you
know dad I love you
and then he's not religious he doesn't
believe in God but in that moment he was
like oh oh man oh my god honey I'm not
even I you know those are those are the
moments in life where I can be like oh
this is what life is about that must've
been really hard for you like trying to
hold that right no it's okay everybody
everybody cries on this podcast for some
reason no way
yeah did like 44 episode somebody cried
yeah for four episodes straight shut up
but that means is a real podcast I mean
dad is so [ __ ] hard because there are
times even with my own dad right that I
have right now because we had such a
tumultuous relationship growing up I
find it hard to say I love you to my dad
you know just because of how we grew up
and kind of how he express his love to
me and my father and I we had a huge
fight a while back and he how he
explained it to me he never heard the
words I love you growing up it just it
just didn't come well especially in that
our culture no way yeah he just didn't
hear it so I mean this is kind of a sad
story but it's also kind of funny but
when I was this was a few years back and
my dad and I has have always had I mean
we got better and better and better as I
was getting older I just became a little
more empathetic and my dad his
testosterone started going down but my
father has always had like this
trolling aspect to his life and to my
fault is that even as he's fixing a lot
of these bad habits that he used to have
or whether he's fixing it or he just
truly just letting go of the control in
my life I still see my dad as that
[ __ ] when I was younger so my instant
reaction I see a lot of kids do this too
because and I'm saying kids and I'm I'm
doing this as well is that we're so used
to that specific type of behavior that
we used to see a lot growing up that we
just want to snap back instantly I can't
remember what the exact argument is
anymore but it basically developed into
a conversation where my dad was saying
like well you know you you came out
pretty good because or you know in your
career because of the things that I
taught you and I looked at him and it
kind of triggered something and I looked
at him I was like what did you teach me
oh boy you know he goes I will I
supported you and you know what you
wanted to do one other hold on a second
I was like oh you didn't you didn't you
didn't support me you exactly you
actually did the exact opposite like you
know I talked about this where he talked
about comedy college and office this
whole like thing about it but at the end
of the day like I looked at him I
remember I was a very sad moment but at
the same time it was kind of funny
because he said to me and this was a
very kind of like I felt like my world
closing in and it kind of hit me really
hard because he I remember I've never
seen my dad cry before
for me I seen my dad cry for my brother
but he's never ever talking about let me
tell you about this [ __ ] real quick
right I'm talking about this [ __ ]
remember what time my my dad and my
brother got into a fight because my dad
didn't like the girl that my brother was
with at the time right she was a little
younger and there was just this whole
thing where my dad just didn't like the
fact that my brother was dating a
younger girl and he just didn't like
that girl in general and so my brother
got into a huge [ __ ] fight to the
point where they were screaming at each
other and my brother looked at my dad
and he goes he goes he goes well my dad
goes is this how you speak to your
father and my brother looked at him he
goes he goes father he goes don't even
say that you're my father he goes from
here on out I don't want to be your son
anymore so don't ever ever call me your
son and don't ever say that I'm your
father do when my dad heard that come
from my brother's mouth this phone just
laid on the couch and started
and I just saw my dad's heart breaking I
looked at my brother my brother's crying
too and as I looked at that the first
thing that popped in my head was I said
that two years ago and you kicked me out
you didn't cry you said that I was like
he wasn't fazed yo this dude is my ass
all that hold on a second I
I'm the JIT yo let me tell you about
this right this is a true [ __ ] story
my dad like a couple years before that
we got into a huge [ __ ] argument
right I was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm
moving out then I'm leaving right and I
was calling this [ __ ] bluff son
I was like I'm [ __ ] out my dad's like
all right [ __ ] leave then I was like
I will leave [ __ ] this [ __ ] I was like
this one go let me leave it's winters
it's cold outside it's it's the winter
is coming all right
oh you know what I'm saying so I I went
outside I remember this moment to die
was like this [ __ ] he's gonna
know he's made a mistake because I'm a G
and I'm gonna walk outside he's gonna
wish he didn't send me outside I
remember I walked outside I closed her I
heard I heard a slight hum I was that
when do we get that lock why that lock
so big oh what's going on yo I said out
there just my [ __ ] shorts in my tee
shots in just a couple minutes I'd
knocked on the door he goes I thought
you were leaving good guys so that's how
he treats me and then with my brother he
does his [ __ ] he goes oh my oldest son I
was gonna ask all right
he's the firstborn same thing when me
and my sister yeah he's the firstborn so
he was he's the golden child yeah my mom
loves yeah yeah yeah I talk about her I
talk about this all the time my mom
loves my sister so much more like my
brother can do absolutely no anything
and everything I didn't really realize
that [ __ ] I'm like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] set me on the Coulter died
I moved out when I was 18
oh [ __ ] I made my own money I moved out
you know yeah I mean I mean the
household was kind of crazy for you to
want to stay in yeah but you know I'm
saying like I was just what I was gonna
ask that was my question when are you
the younger one cuz I just feel like
that's that what younger you know the
youngest one has to pass ago I mean I
was like hyper rebellious too
just because I hated somebody telling me
how I should be and I've always hated
that even till this day that's still how
I am it wasn't a phase and my parents I
think they always thought it was going
to be a face that I was gonna grow out
of and for them understandably so I
wasn't an easy kid but it was never a
phase for me I've always just been that
kid that was like you tell me to go left
I'm gonna go right just because you said
that left was okay let me figure it out
for myself first
and I usually a lot of people maybe you
would think so but it's not the case a
lot of people you know that's a phase
for some people for me it's never a face
that was just who I am I think it is I
think I think maybe it's just I don't
maybe it's like that artistic side of
our brain like maybe we don't want to
take we don't want one plus one to
always equal to three also leadership
right baby I like I like leading I don't
like following I like a little bit of
both yeah I'm saying like sometimes I
like waking up and not having to think
about [ __ ] well yeah I'm talking oh yeah
you're right if there's days that yeah
I'm talking about like you're like yeah
I don't like I always end up being the
person walking ahead of everyone even
though I don't know where the
destination is that's stupid though all
right guys let's go to this restaurant
you know what are you going yep that's
[ __ ] crazy though that you actually
told your dad I love you and because in
my mind I'm thinking about yo I guess as
a young person or as as a kid I would
think you know because you weren't
around and you chose to leave like you
left me with two men that beat me you
know and that was something that I wish
that you were there for and at the same
time I wouldn't think that you would I I
guess for me from an outside looking in
I was like you don't deserve to hear to
say I love you because you weren't
around and if you were maybe things
could have been different and that's the
hard part right because I mean for you I
think you're religious as well so you
have to find this this other reason
behind it and you have to really kind of
step out of yourself you have to see a
different perspective so this is what I
say to people about when you know God
gets in the picture uh
I don't think I was a [ __ ] person before
I do always think I had a kind heart
alright fine art but I can definitely
say before kiyah I was on a career path
and I was on a path that I really I knew
I was gonna be good right yeah and I
think if I kept going there I would have
met God you know and I don't know if I
would sit here with you yeah and be your
friend I don't know if you would want to
be my friend well you know you're
sucking dick all the time
yeah yeah but I was very career-driven
like nothing really faced me it was just
about me it's about me I you know I'm
trying to not be so hard on myself
because I don't think I'm a mean person
I love people but you know but that was
a people pleaser and that's because my
insecurities right but honestly why I go
to God is because I can't [ __ ] handle
my damn self you know I got [ __ ] that I
can't stand you know and the only way
and no one I don't listen to people
that's my stubbornness so the only one I
can listen to because he runs my life
like I can die tomorrow if I wanted to
write is I'm telling you while I was
going through my to forest and I moved
out that house and I was learning how to
be a single mom you know I don't get
financial help you know like I've been
doing this on my own since 18 you know
so I all I could do was [ __ ] fall to
my knees and just start crying cuz I had
no idea what to do yeah and no one can
help me no one you know so that is why I
you know I always talk about I always
kind of bring up God because without him
honestly I just wouldn't be here as a
mother as s just me but it's such a
weird thing like I think like especially
on this podcast people know who I am
like religion is such a touchy subject
fro it is you know I think I mean how I
always explain religion to people my
[ __ ] is man it's like what I eat don't
make you [ __ ] so you know if if my path
leads me this way and it makes me happy
so like so excited I had a conversation
with a friend and he goes well you know
I wouldn't picture you as a typical
Christian right was like yeah very true
like you're not wrong with that
you know and he asked me you know with
all the knowledge out there and you've
seen like logically a lot of things
don't make sense I was like you and
you're a hundred percent right and my
egg he goes like well don't you feel
like you're wasting your life you know
kind of pinpointing a lot of you a lot
of the things that you do based on this
deity that's not around I was like that
is a great perspective you know and I
completely understand and I was and I
said but and I was like maybe this is
the wrong approach and maybe this is not
very christ-like for me to say but I'm
like well what's that take away from you
you know
why does it why does it bother you that
I'm doing something that doesn't take
away from you or for somebody else you
know aside from like you see a lot of
extremely religious people who do a lot
of hateful things well I'm not one of
those dudes so what I mean by that is if
I said if I took this gamble and I said
whatever you know God Jesus exists right
and to me he does right and I go out and
I live my life and this having this
purpose in my life makes me happy but in
your mind you're like what you live for
this person that doesn't exist but at
the end of the day I died happy
so who's what am I missing out on yeah
you know so what am I missing out on
like if I said like if I came up to
yours like oh you you wanna try this god
you just think yeah you're like nah
that's [ __ ] it's too big well I can't
change your mind okay some peace out
yeah is what it is I will still be
friends here's the thing like I realize
when people talk because you know when
people talk to me they I when I bring up
God they're like oh you're what are you
I'm like I love God that's what I I
don't know that's what that's that's it
so and they start talking to me and they
start talking me about all this
judgmental [ __ ] I'm sorry I need to stop
cussing but
but you know honestly they're just like
you know God is so judgmental the
Bible's judgmental and I was like here's
the thing though when I started reading
the Bible and I started reading from the
beginning from the jump and oh that
should put me to sleep but it used to do
but now I see so much of myself and what
I do in it so I'm just like how be in
the BC days was I thinking the same [ __ ]
and when when this [ __ ] was happening
cuz patterns exist this is why human
nature [ __ ] keeps happening the same way
it's just what's happening right now is
in the Bible so I I just it was crazy to
me and when I usually talk to people
that say that it's you know this is very
judgmental I asked them I was like do
you have you read the whole Bible have
you read the Bible that they're like no
okay well here's the thing I can't
really it's hard to conversate with
people now that don't really have the
knowledge but have judgment like you're
talking about that girl earlier right
because you know i-i-i like to try
things out I've tried Buddhism I was
seeking you know and I I do think it's
beautiful but it wasn't it wasn't for me
I tried it I tried it and that's me I
tried a lot of things in my life and I
know what I would like and what I don't
like and what works for me and what
doesn't and I know about every religion
so but here's the thing here's one thing
I did realize I did meet someone that
told me that they believed in
reincarnation right [ __ ] was real good
man I'll tell you that she'll be tight
though I want it would be I want to be
reborn as a dragon's dragon I want to be
reborn as a dragons immediately okay
here's a thing this was just interesting
it made me it meet it made it really
silly click for me that you know this
person saw their own deaths and their
own reincarnate like them being born
again what they gonna be reborn we are
reborn all right were you ever frog you
know like I was really I was really
interested but they're like no like I
got to relive as a human and I get to
just change what I didn't change back
then from my past life so who was this
person before because that's what I want
to know
and that's all a do I want to know that
who that person was before I want to
know the social security number of that
person before I want to know the
families I want to see everything right
cuz that'd be [ __ ] dope that's crazy
if somebody comes back to life right now
and they go yeah we know
reincarnation is real I was like I for
real who are you before while I was John
of liquor whit's out in out in London in
1952 no that's time I got struck by
lightning seven times right in the PM in
here right in the penis seven times that
my penis exploded and I died I was like
yeah whatever
I googled that [ __ ] right John wick
awakes dick explosion seven times
electricity I'd be like yo that's oh no
but have you seen some of this crazy
like [ __ ] were there are documented
stories or I want to say stories per se
but there were kids who are documented
like for example there was a kid that
was speaking German looking at this
documentary of Hitler right and he goes
this little kid goes oh I was there and
he goes personally what are you Tom he
was I was there he goes he was saying
miss this and that my name is blah blah
blah blah and they're like yo what the
[ __ ] and they looked it up and it was
like real it was true and he was
literally saying everything that he's
never seen this doc before this is a
really young kid and they the kiss
saying that he knows what Hitler was
saying he knows that because he was
there watching him give that speech but
as he got older all these memories start
disappearing and he doesn't remember him
saying that is that how Benjamin Button
came out no Benjamin buttons different
you know Benjamin's buttons like it's
like you come out as a [ __ ] wrinkly
ball sack and then you get you know or
some [ __ ] like that
okay well okay here okay really quick
going back to I was good I'm gonna
finish it real quick okay yeah so I was
looking at him and I was like man you
know what's crazy I think you're crazy
for thinking like going through that
experience but you're thinking that I'm
crazy cuz I hear from God and that's
when I'm that's when I realized man
people just got to be kind of crazy to
believe in anything and I think it's
actual thing like well you gotta step in
faith in anything you believe in right
you mad deep I don't even think that
deep other side I'm just doing me man
you do you know
whoa whoa I get it now I get why you
know people have beliefs because you
know you need to have faith in something
and it I don't know that clicked for me
I was just like oh that's kind of tight
if reincarnation is like legit what you
try to come back is what you trying to
come back as do mmm mad rich okay yeah
everybody would like to come back mad
rich I'm talking about creature person
something person I don't know I don't
want to be a creature I want to come
back there's two things I want to come
back ass I want to come back as a corgi
because a lot of pretty girls love
corgis and I'd be nestled in some nice
ass titties for the rest of my life I
have to do anything about it and they're
gonna cut your balls off that's cool I'm
in some titties and then number two I
would like to come back as a very very
sturdy black man just because I want to
pro few Slee use the end wear without
getting look that way you see I'll be
ready okay you see that word a lot bro
it's like dude I've been waiting for
this moment I was I was a fat Korean
dude before people give me the I when I
was saying it do you say it not as much
anymore slips out every now and then
yeah like it's definitely built in me
like we had a podcast about this with a
couple of friends of mine were you know
it just is something that I tried not to
say but it slips out just because a lot
of my my friends say a lot specifically
in Sacramento so when they're saying it
like I'm saying it and I don't even know
that I'm saying it and then I have to
catch myself a little [ __ ] that's right
this is this is you know it's just China
the same man like there's no point
there's no need for you say yeah there's
definitely no need but I grew up saying
it's a little little kid like I'm
talking about little little kid so yeah
you know I'm trying not to do it much
anymore it's just sometimes in in these
Hollywood streets I'd be hearing some
people saying it I'm just like if it's a
popular thing man like I don't want to
be too redundant on this podcast but
it's just people have this this
necessity to say it they feel like they
need to say it it's like I want to but
it's like why do you need to and that's
that's what we always bless what it
boils down to is something as simple as
that but yeah that's crazy though I mean
you let's say you I mean you went from
the whole situation with you know
growing up with like two abusive
stepfather
and then somehow wrapping that around
into meeting your father as an adult
later on with your own kid and being
able to say I love you to him and then
you also mention I mean because I know
about this because you were going
through it at the time but you were you
were married
obviously when you had when you had care
and so I mean do you see I mean this is
kind of straightforward but do you see a
lot of the I guess like how you develop
a lot of relationships with males in
your life tend to be sometimes a little
bit of skew because of the relationships
that you had when you were younger with
men especially with these abusive
fathers yes okay so one thing though um
my mom did remarry a Jewish man so I'm
part Jewish something okay but he's an
amazing amazing amazing father
I don't even call you know Stephanie
he's ice the first day I met him I was
like one can I get your credit card too
hi father
you know so it ends up good okay but I
do have to say that that's a lot of
where my self-reflections
have been coming from you know
self-awareness because I do have a
daughter and I really I I don't know how
to do this you guys it's being a parent
there's no guidelines and there's no
baby if there is it doesn't [ __ ]
matter it's what everybody tells me yeah
cuz it's every kid is different so I
just want to make sure I I really just
want to make sure she doesn't grow up
with my issues right and I don't want to
have any hatred spewing out for any men
like I don't want her to grow that way I
want her to grow up having her mind of
her own but just setting like a good
foundation right like loving emotion
like great foundation so I did realize
before I did realize that as the things
that I have experienced has definitely
has definitely skewed with my emotions
and my mind and what I thought love was
so I've had a lot of abusive boyfriend's
like being tossed across the room like
so what are you through us yeah through
my I do a dancer you let on your feet
though
nice try I'm a dancer [ __ ]
you said plie toss mean I was like W by
WWE yeah yeah it's really helped wait
how did he do this um uh it's like my
bed was like right here and he was I
can't he like put well he did like
karate forever so I I don't remember he
didn't kick me but he pushed me and all
I remember I had a CD case right here
and I flew and I hit that again what led
to that what was the argument about um
well you said his karate sucked it's
like you know what you know yeah buddy
thanks [ __ ] and you're like everyone
knows better [ __ ] no it didn't nothing
um I think we're just we're it was just
a bad relationship it was a lot of drugs
involved like you know um I was really
young and he he I think he was on
something but what was the reason like
what happened like you got you just came
into the door yo hey sweetie
[ __ ] you he's just a really abusive
relationship but I like you know we
would have but what was the catalyst in
that situation I don't even know honest
yeah you just started throwing you well
that night well it was a blur some of
the nights were blurs cuz we'll be
drinking right but you know he would
have it was just a really bad
relationship and but I so the physical
abuse part of relationships stopped at a
certain age because I was like okay that
has to go right there's something wrong
with me if I think that's love but still
I didn't realize I was still surround
like I was still accepting guys who
didn't um respect me you know so they
emotionally abuse me and I thought up
that was okay how would they emotionally
abused you I mean doing dumb [ __ ] you
know like turning off their phone and
going out all night and saying that I'm
a crazy [ __ ] and you asked them you
know like things like that like there
are major signs that a girl should you
know really really re-evaluate
themselves and
their relationships and be like okay
this is not good for me so I need to go
but that wasn't my process mine was like
oh I have hope because he must really
love me if he keeps coming back to me oh
you got that Savior [ __ ] yes yep
captain save up person yeah captain
captain save a bro yeah save a bro there
you go yeah that's really what it is you
know I there's a lot of girls who do
that too yeah you know guys too but
there's a lot of girls I think this
whole thing they're like you haven't
seen his good side I see his real side
yeah see that's that was me yeah and
that's what's [ __ ] crazy I'm sorry to
call my friends out but they already
know like I say that to them I hear that
from a lot of people around me now and
I'm just like I'm psycho let me tell you
something my guy karate kicked me in my
face I know what's up I'm good I don't I
would love to meet a great person that
would be a great like a part of the
family but yeah I am so good not being
in these situations I hear ya you know
cuz a lot of it sounds sounds sad cuz
it's like it's a circle that's so
interesting man
like that's why I'm talking about like I
definitely wanted to talk to you about
this just because you know there's
obviously there's like layers to this
[ __ ] like you grew up younger in a very
just kind of shaky household
specifically with these terrible male
figures and it translates over as you
get older in your own personal
relationships and I think sometimes it's
kind of cool that you realize that
because it's it's hard like me having
this conversation sometimes with other
people who haven't I I would say reach
this level of realization or maturity
because when you say to them hey you're
your expectations of what you think a
man should be is wrong it's not right
because of what you've experienced when
you're younger but what they hear that
it's like oh you think I'm dumb and you
think I don't know what I'm doing I know
exactly what I'm doing but there's this
other side to this coin where you have
to think like well nobody's saying it's
your fault what they're saying is that
you've experienced something very
traumatic and it's [ __ ] up with the
way that you're viewing healthy
relations
there's it's it's it's very evident it's
highly evident now as an adult where I'm
talking about I can name at least like 8
or 10 people in my life that I've met
that grew up with very terrible
situations growing up whether it was
physical abuse sexual abuse father
leaving them or all three all three
they've all had the most difficult time
setting up healthy relationships with
male figures in their life because they
are trying to construct what yeah
positive male figures because they
haven't experienced it yet
so it either happens as the the negative
stuff that they're seeing in men are
stuff that they're attracted to because
it's what they're are cause they're
accustomed to they're used to or to
their having very a hard time having a
successful relationship because in their
mind they're saying that men have to be
like I'm charming act is the in this
Disney type of world right yes because
that's the positive side that they saw
growing up but that's not real
it's [ __ ] that's what I'm saying I
think you'll be a great father you guys
would be great parents you know cuz you
have a great foundation and like I know
there's no guideline but if you have a
good foundation that's where it starts
you know mine I did I didn't have a good
foundation so I'm learning I'm doing
backwards [ __ ] you know and I have to do
it quick you know she's four but that's
absolutely right I I grew up with the
mentality of the world owed me something
because I kept a lot of [ __ ] in right
and instead of letting that anger and
that pain out I was just like well you
know I had to deal with this when I was
younger so I deserve like I know I
deserve something betters you know like
I you know I I thought the world owed me
something I thought God owed me
something but um that's the [ __ ] I don't
like that's why I don't like kale
watching Disney movie movies anymore
it's because she's starting to say
Prince Charming is gonna save me
oh my gosh are you kidding me and it
still it I do understand why parents
don't allow their kids to watch certain
shows right I don't think they should
ban them from watching shows VeggieTales
is a good way to go or
VeggieTales are still popping right now
yeah cucumbers cucumbers and the
tomatoes you know and but they're all
about positivity and like with Disney
music music movies they really embed in
there in the kid's brain cuz I have to
watch like five got to watch it like
numerous of times right because of kaea
and now I'm adult so I'm really watching
this as that's why you got to show this
without real humans like Lion King yeah
I'm saying yeah it it really is about
Prince Charming and it's about false
false hopes and false dreams about false
fantasies well that's what I think
everybody liked about the let it go
what's that one called frozen cuz there
was about two strong female characters
right and there wasn't a prince charming
there to save everybody there was a male
figure there trying to save somebody but
he wasn't one that saved the day it was
a sister you know so I don't I don't
know like for me I want to mind them
watching Disney but I do understand it's
hard to get a kid to understand that
there isn't this this magical world
maybe there's a lot of positivity and
love in this world but you can't expect
this myth this male figure to come and
save you every time it's maybe a several
frozen but you go know that great music
tho yo I'm gonna be honest right now
when you start watching Street fret I
don't buy that damn you have a good
voice if only they'd look closer would
they see a po-boy no siree really ryx
yeah oh sure they find out there's so
much more yeah [ __ ] that movie you know
what about Robin Williams right now I
love Robin Willis
but this is what I heard okay and I was
I walk like you don't like brown people
go no whoa you know but no no someone
made a point where this goes with the
prince charming jasmine falls in love
with the [ __ ] crook he's a [ __ ]
crook he's he's not a crook he's a riff
raff street rat I don't buy that if only
they'd look closer if he's talking about
you right now
he's talking about you if only she'd
look closer now it would they see a poor
boy
no she won't there's no there's nothing
cuz I found a but he's just a big ol
[ __ ] no but this person made a lot of
sense saying you know like it's showing
kids like that you can steal and you
still can you know they're not they're
not showing you that you could steal and
be Prince Charming you have to look at
the whole situation right but you think
of it as a child it's like what your way
I don't think that's what kids are
thinking though I don't think when I was
a kid I what look Aladdin came out when
we were kids I never thought from once
watching that film that stealing was
okay but I thought bad boys are pretty
hot well that's cool you're all [ __ ]
up you got daddy issues
girls love bad boys right yeah but you I
don't I don't think I think you're
looking too into it because because
yourself cuz you're saying cuz cuz
you're actually doing the exact opposite
of what you're saying you're saying
right now that kids don't know any
better and that's what they're gonna
take away from it and I'm telling you me
as a kid right yeah okay I all I thought
was cool magic carpet a lot of great
magic something happens in the end that
makes me happy there's no way that a
young child is thinking oh stealing is
really cool and if I steal this is best
because that's not even anywhere near
the notes that are expressed in that
film that's such a small part of the
film that just gets glazed over okay
here's the thing as a parent as a mother
who has a child I know you're coming
through experience right yeah but I'm
watching these movies with her right and
I'm really seeing that I don't like
these movies they they actually say bad
words like I don't want my child hear
the word stupid repeatedly right because
she wants to watch these movies they
actually the if you start watching this
stuff with your kids you start noticing
the stories the actual characters the
the actual intentions someone I don't
know if I can I give you another
perspective though you yes you may so
you are also looking this as the eyes of
somebody as an adult who has been
through a lot of things right so your
your perspective in my personal opinion
your
into things that I don't think kids will
pick up at all awesome and also to this
is what I believe because mind you too
like I'm talking about like we grew up
in a generation where Disney was huge
you know and I've never really seen that
effect of like I can understand the
whole prince charming effect do you
understand what I'm saying but for me
right now you're also trying to do this
thing where I see it as you're also
trying to shield your kid from stuff
that they're gonna see with or without
you she watches this he I take it or
watch Disney for sure but I can't stop
no I'm not gonna stop her but I will
limit her you know I will limit the
amount of what she watches and what she
you know like there's no way she's gonna
grow up and not being able to watch this
she'll do it behind my back I get that
but what what I'm telling you is when
you have a child and you see what
they're you're listening to what they're
saying
you start understanding what these shows
and these movies actually [ __ ] what
what is embedded in their brain my
daughter only thinks princes are blonde
haired girls I'm being honest and you
know I don't want you think she thinks
princes are blonde hair there are only
blonde accesses princesses are only
blonde haired girls no shade in that
there's no shade but the fact that you
know it this is like I bought this I
bought this thing whereas a bunch of
stickers of just a bunch of girls and
you could trust them however you want
and this is where I really noticed it
where she picked all the blonde girls
and make them very pretty and put crowns
on them and she was and she's like this
is a princess she's so beautiful and
she'll pick out any other race and I'm
like is she a princess - she's like no
she's ugly
hmm because even as a nation you know
like her as an image like she doesn't
think she's a princess she was like I'm
not a princess and so I was like whoa
[ __ ] this is why I think it is deeper
and when you have a child you you will
start seeing oh I'm just talking about
the magic carpet and that and that
thieving scene
oh no I agree that part yeah I mean like
I'm saying like those imagery the the
imagery of the whole princess thing and
the Prince Charming thing because it's a
theme that happens so often in these
older Disney films like I
I completely get that I was just talking
about that I get it that could take it
to another level that's all we're
talking about two separate yeah that was
because I was on a roll with all this
like I was realize for sure I mean yeah
it does your desk and see that too cause
like you know in these toys that kids
see they they'll pick out the ones that
they'll see in these films a lot because
that's people that they'll want to like
emulate a lot right so that's why in
media now a lot of people are fighting
for these diverse characters to have
these type of roles because they're want
they want their kids to understand that
yo you could be a princess you be a hero
in your own story and you could do it by
looking the way that you do now exactly
and I think they you know things are
changing but I do have to be honest with
you that's what my daughter that's what
my daughter says so you know I'm just
trying to now
yo what if you asked cares like it's
mommy a pretty she goes no I'm not a
princess last year room mommy is a
princess all right you see I'm a queen
there's no point no you ain't married
girl you a princess
oh yeah you're right I'm good with that
yeah but why was i goodness but you know
i grew up with the whole prince charming
like saving me cuz I remember watching
Little Mermaid and I do it came to a
point in my life where I was like well
why do I think like this well why well
why well yeah you know cuz I was
constantly watching Little Mermaid you
know so I as a child it's you don't know
anything so they are very smart because
they're sponges but it's it's really
really really really really really
really important what what is feeding
their brains oh for sure like there's no
argument in that um like for me to like
I'm gonna you know when I have a kid
hopefully I'll try and do my best
it's just I think sometimes like I think
as parents what there's when there's so
much knowledge out there a lot of
parents get tend to get paranoid so [ __ ]
yeah yeah but you know you have to look
at it like this too you know I grew up
fine a lot of my other friends grew up
fine too
like I say a fat chunk of it so for
example like like I'll use as an example
right people have kids now and they go
oh they need this this this and this
they need to have the high-tech stroller
everything else and then if not then
they're not going to
up as good kids just like no well no
first of all we're [ __ ] animals we'll
survive yeah like we will [ __ ]
survive nothing's gonna happen to your
[ __ ] kid unless you're out here just
having your kid on a [ __ ] link chain
around the throat and swinging them
around like they'll be completely okay
like I just don't want to be in a
position where sometimes I see a lot of
people trying to shield their kid from
the world I don't think that smart
either yeah yeah you know I'm not saying
you're doing that I'm just saying that
it just tends to be something that I get
worried out that that I might do because
my dad tried to do that for me you know
my dad always had an issue with he
wanted me to be a very strong and
independent person but when I would try
to do things for myself he would take it
away from me and say you know what I'll
do it cuz you can't do it right but what
he was doing he just didn't want to see
me fail at things and he wanted to do
things for me cuz he wanted to protect
me but the problem with that was that he
was making me into a Nannette human
being I couldn't do things for my own
and I just had the balls enough to say
one day I was like stop doing [ __ ] for
me I want to do it myself let me make my
own mistakes you know so for my dad like
he goes well why don't you want your dad
to help you was like it's not that I
don't want you to help me you have to
allow me to learn yeah let me do my [ __ ]
and in his mind he goes well I was the
one that put you in those situations
that taught you out of learning like I
took you I took you to the business you
did this this and that great you did do
that I do appreciate but there was just
other half that I want to try out but
you just would never let me do it it
would just he would take it away from me
go so you know what I'm just gonna do it
myself you know and it was because I
feel like at that time my dad wanted me
to be a strong person but because I was
about the same that he wanted to protect
me a little too much and so there's like
some certain kids too dude I had a
cousin who didn't know how to use who
didn't know how to go to a bank account
or open up a bank account at a bank
I'd like to age like 21 oh my gosh you
know what I'm saying like [ __ ] like that
like he called me up I'm younger than
him and he goes eight how do I open up a
bank I did he walked in the bank he goes
no why don't you just go and ask
questions because everything was done
for him yeah no I get that
you know trust me but I I also like you
said I think everything is in layers
right it's like your the way your
father's upbringing and how he had to
you know be to where he was at with you
raising you I think
thing stems from somewhere and yeah
that's when now I like I said I only I
had a lot of anger towards my mom a lot
you know cuz I told you I bottle a lot
of things in she didn't know about a lot
of the stuff that was happening in that
house to a couple of years ago but that
was my problem because I didn't talk
about it
so in the past year I've started to ask
my mom a lot of questions about her
childhood and I this is the number one
thing I've learned was to shut the [ __ ]
up
I told Lydia I loved Lydia she's my
sister last year in December I was I was
just be talking to her and all sudden
I'll be like like I don't feel good
right now I'm telling you I'm being
serious David where I was like I don't I
don't feel good like I don't want to
talk anymore I just feel like I don't
want to talk I feel like I'm just
talking a lot of [ __ ] and I wasn't
you know and then I just kept on trying
to have conversations even just with her
and I there's just something in my head
was like shut the [ __ ] up yeah I'm being
honest so I was like okay you know what
I want to listen to this thing this
voice in my head and I'm gonna shut the
[ __ ] up mm-hmm and I just started
listening and then that made me realize
hey I listen to people but maybe I
should do this with people who are
closest to me you know like like if I
could hear the stranger out let me hear
some of these things that I'm holding it
like I have issues with so I started
asking my mom about her past and her
childhood and literally listening to her
for hours and gosh Dan David like like
there were funny ass [ __ ] stories I
was like damn mommy oh [ __ ] Jean I
didn't even know that [ __ ] you're more
of a G than me you know like I thought
you know and that that was our anytime
but she had amazing stories she had very
funny stories and she had such crazy sad
stories of you know her childhood and I
I cannot even though I went through what
I went through David there's my mother
went through some [ __ ] and our cult
the Korean culture is to shut the [ __ ]
up she grew up being like no one told
her they loved her she'd even know who
her parents were or who and she didn't
know because that's just the culture so
that's why she raised me without saying
I love you without thinking without
having any like I don't like myself I
mean there's the culture aspect too but
I guess what I'm saying really quick is
just that I I just start listening yeah
because we only got one life to live you
know and I I really don't want to live
it continuously with with questions and
my own my own idea of what I think
happened and that it also goes back to
like I was mentioned before you even in
your life like your mom did the best
that she could yeah but she had yeah and
you know you're just a better iteration
of what she had cuz even you said
yourselves like what I went through was
nothing compared to what she went
through so you know for her as a parent
her giving you the life that you had she
was just doing her best from the female
the situation that she had which is a
very enlightening moment you know and
and then now you're gonna have to take
your experiences and try to make sure
Kia has a better experience with that as
well you know but you never you're never
gonna know and I need the hard part to
that with some of my friends who have
other who have older kids so like oh
[ __ ] I tried my best and there's they're
kind of [ __ ] up the same way I did
it's like well you just never know
people are individuals - there's a
gamble with it yes you know you never
know so that's where I'm at like like
you know I let kayo figure things out on
her own when we do homework
we obviously I helped her but my kid it
on dubs flood my kids don't ask me some
shared they're like that what's algebra
I go to your [ __ ] room yeah geometry
I'm good I'm like I need to get you a
tutor but yeah I I could only understand
your dad on a certain on one sense of
like trying to protect your child so a
quick story is that you know Kia had
said she got her first stitches right
and yeah she took it like a G but I got
a call that she fell she didn't cry at
all but she you know when I went to her
she fell and bashed her head against
this what you know something sharp and
her meat was just [ __ ] hanging out
dude she was like chillin right
kids baby yeah and and she and you know
she's tough she's a tough girl
I let her [ __ ] do what she you know
but take like watching her so we took
her to the emergency right so first of
all the time she's chillin she's chillin
the [ __ ] doctors they try gluing her
stitches together and I think that's the
first time a nurse did it
so his gloves got stuck in her [ __ ]
meat that was coming out and on her hair
so when he tried to pull out it pulled
his hand of fingers out he ripped her
hair out and like it was a mess and so
before so they took 30 minutes to put
pressure against her meat to
continuously try to take the glue out
girl was even crying just yet and I was
I don't know how [ __ ] she's holding this
together cuz it was like 1:00 a.m. we
were already waiting for five hours okay
so finally she has to come the doctor
comes in saying she has to get stitches
girl is so tired she doesn't even know
what's going on the other patient is
wailing like it's scary in there and
they have to take this blanket and wrap
her around it so she can't move and one
nurse is holding her here doctors over
there
her dad's over here and I my job was to
hold her legs down and I didn't know
stitches like I have stitches but I
never saw it you know being done to me
but it's this [ __ ] hook like you
wouldn't you would think they would have
a better solution by now but the
Bissell's okay so this thick ass hook is
piercing her skin and I just see blood
coming down and she's like that's when
she's like like I've never seen my kid
do this but her neck was like this and
she turned bright red and she's kicking
screaming they didn't um the area no no
where did you go to a [ __ ] emergency
in Compton Bank in Burbank and she's
like no they numbed a little bit but I
think you know she still can feel it but
I've never seen my daughter like that
and I just remember in that moment I was
just like I don't know what to do
because she's staring at
screaming and screaming and I can't do
anything to take that pain from her and
these are just stitches dude and I'm
like I I couldn't handle it and then
once she started reaching up for me when
it was done I just remember I was like I
can't I can't I can't breathe and I
tried crack water and I woke up on the
floor and then I flicking got admitted
to the hospital because I fainted you
fainted because well that day was really
emotional for me I was going through
other [ __ ] and I didn't eat the whole
night and I was there trying to take
care of her and I liked how your your
daughter is reaching out for help and
then you fate exactly but then she now
she always goes mommy do you remember
when when you fell in hits a trash can I
felt that's [ __ ] funny my head bang
the trashcan as I fainted but her memory
is that she's trying to grab me and I
faint and I [ __ ] bat bang my head a
trash can but she was like I won't and
then that's what she said
I won't I won't I I won't make a boo-boo
again you know cuz she doesn't want me
to you know faint but like those are the
moments where I'm like I understand
parents now because because she's she's
my blood right she's come out of my
[ __ ] vagina and I held her the love
that you have for your child and the
fact that you can't take their pain away
from something that they need to learn
is the most like devastating thing as a
parent you can go through that's the
only interesting cuz like like I hear
these stories you know cuz I like I said
I don't have a kid but they're so
there's like your thing and then there's
like the other thing where I know
parents who don't feel that way yeah I
mean like they see their kid go through
the stuff and then how they process it
is like they're almost like proud of
their kid it's like oh they're handling
this pretty well yes our Father they
don't feel the that emotional pain of
like my kids going through pain they're
just more like hah that sucks but you
know what they're gonna get through it
you know I wonder if that's more of like
um well you know I heard that from guys
so maybe it's like a girl thing you know
what I mean I think it's because
honestly it's because I carried her
right you feel everything you feel every
kick you feel you feel you feel your
baby in your body which is a trip you
know I'm saying and when you it that's a
whole nother experience that I don't
expect guys to understand that's why
women are just geared to be more like
you know empathetic I think yeah my mom
nurturer my mom has some of that but the
other side she really doesn't because I
remember this one time let me tell you
this story when I was a kid and I might
have told this [ __ ] to but it was I'm
talking about I was madly in love with
this girl when I was 18 years old um she
and I broke up when I was 19 and I
remember this because I came back home
from college and I had just gone through
this heartbreak and I was sulking in my
room my mom knows something is wrong and
then she looks at me she goes whoa you
know I should talk this is before I
actually I'm [ __ ] things up this is
before I went in to go soak in my room
and she goes oh what happened as I was
got dumped and I'm crying and I looked
at my I'm just like don't tell that
about anything I go into the room and I
remember my mom opens the door that she
comes up to me and she puts her hand on
my shoulder as I'm crying she goes only
little [ __ ] crying gets up walks out
and closes the door I think that's funny
yeah of course what going through it no
I'm Lydia it might if care went through
I'll be like oh but I'll probably say
the same thing cuz it's funny you want
to say that [ __ ] to your kid at all
you don't eat good old braids you know
you barely you when you first had kid
with shoes of you barely could
discipline her dude you were never you
would not say that to your kid you don't
have that at your mom we have jokes so
meet care got jokes but we Mian can't
have jokes like that's if you're if your
daughter was crying in her room you
would not come up to him be like stop
being a [ __ ] get up and walk out I
don't know I think that's very funny
I think that what do you like I said
it's right now Latinas like a level
close closeness
no we weren't that close back there she
rose just roasted my ass and left
that's it tight-ass mom you wouldn't
even deal you'd be like care I can't see
you cry because it makes me cry that you
cried more than her in the case like yo
[ __ ] chill out no I don't know about
a breakup though when it's oh yes you
know when it's physical pain I can't
stand that [ __ ] cuz I can't see what I
see your daughter cry from getting
having our heart broken you're gonna
feel terrible the first one cuz you're
like [ __ ] [ __ ] men and their
stupid dicks just swinging that thing
about it's [ __ ] the one-eyed monster
just spinning around in a circle
disgusting
no my god dude yeah my mom I mean that's
I mean so full circle with you I mean I
guess like I mean it sees you you I
think you've done pretty well for
yourself you know thank you you know all
these obstacles I mean you know do we
even begin to talk about any of your dad
stuff I'd rather talk about this oh yeah
for sure you know um it's kind of crazy
though like I said like all the stuff
that you've gone through like I've I've
talked about this with a lot of like
girlfriends who go through these type of
similar situations and there's a lot of
like self healing yourself thought
self-reflecting that that has to go on
and it has to take place and there is
this moment where I feel like maybe even
for you and even for a few of my other
friends or they just have to say like oh
[ __ ] my perspective is skewed yep not to
my fault you know is but it's because of
things that happened and once you had
that moment of realization where you
realize like okay maybe I am in shambles
right now and we all are all broken you
know but the moment you're allowed to
say that out loud and you truly accept
that and you can start picking up those
pieces and start putting it together
yeah you know but if you're if you're
that type of human being who goes
through these type of traumatic
experiences and you still look at the
world and you say it's the rest of the
world's fault you're never gonna get
never
that's dude that's exactly what I was
about to say is the number I think the
number one thing that helps me I'm so
hard was holding myself accountable oh
that's hard dude but I hate doing that
[ __ ] man I hate I hate looking in the
mirror saying like dude this is actually
a lot of it's because of you yeah and
you don't want to accept that
yeah like even when I [ __ ] up with
Marielle dude I did this thing now like
what man when I say something I know I
[ __ ] that Maris I well you know you
did wrong right and I'm like guilty
thought I can't look in her eyes I'm
like okay what's that look at my eyes I
can't look okay look in your eyes right
now I [ __ ] up yeah but that's amazing
that you can do that you know a lot it
takes me a little longer you know I have
to actually let it soak in a little bit
but then I will but at least you get
there and you know some people don't and
that's that's sad yeah cuz then you know
they're just living a life that's just
kind of like you know in their own
bubble and it's hard to be around people
like that yeah and I think that's the
number one thing I think is really
helpful number one is to like really see
it right and then to see it and be like
oh [ __ ] okay I see this and then second
I think what is really hard to do is to
hold yourself accountable because I mean
that's when you have the choice to
change yeah well I think that's like an
hour in like almost 20 minutes in dude
dude we ran through that [ __ ] yeah I you
know you're so hate me yeah bi straight
up you know what I shouldn't even call
this genius pray I just call just
therapy yeah oh my gosh yeah yeah you
actually should yes interesting they
like cuz when I started this podcast I I
didn't I didn't know where it was gonna
go you know just because I don't more
having conversation I'm not thinking
about the type of conversations that
we're having yeah but I guess like a
what a what I guess I don't know this
about myself but then you know my mom
said this about me two years you have a
way of when you speak to people just
things come out you know and maybe she's
cuz we're really comfortable with each
other but it's like these are the type
of stories I really like because
everybody when they go through something
they think that they're the only person
going through it yeah you know they
always think that they're the only one
and that's how a lot of people honestly
they get depressed because they get
stuck in this dark hole yeah I've just
it's only me going through this why is
this happening why is this happening to
me and I think like a part of this huge
podcast it's like I want to show people
like you know there's a lot of people in
my life but you tell me these personal
stories you know I have friends who are
going to them and they're coming out of
this this darkness so you know it's
you're just you're just not alone
you're really not and you're that's
that's beautiful
like that you know this is great because
that's why I was holding a lot of anger
back was because I didn't think anyone
understood me you know no wonder mom
story and said oh [ __ ] look at that but
yes but I took a lot of like
self-awareness before I even asked you
know it's more like I don't know what
that was in my head being like shut the
[ __ ] up but it really helps me be like
okay let me yes having a kid getting
older just you know just that maturity
when I say this - they're like oh I feel
like there's a small amount of people
that all you think you know everything I
know I'm older than you
so I've much I'm saying that I'm just
saying this now just to plant the seed I
think when you're 20 years old 18 and 19
you're not gonna get it now and that's
okay I'm saying it's a hundred percent
okay yeah but at least what I can do is
what my parents did for me is just plant
the seed and then eventually something
will come from it yeah you know that's
all well guys um damn we went into a lot
of topics today we talked about just
parenting so much about just like daddy
issues just going from the pain and
everything else yo I didn't expect this
one to get that [ __ ] deep so my god
I'm really sorry when you know get
really deep in it damn I think these
people just saw me just scratch at my
toes for a solid light hour just like
I'm just like this great to see ya I
don't know what to be honest I [ __ ]
hate feet and I just been like sing
don't I you know I didn't want ya now
just like watching you doing that
whatever I don't know how don't you ever
touched me with those hands ever again
first of all I took a shower before you
I got man
don't you never you I got your feet with
a tarantella wack anyways guys so what
can they find you um hope no but um
social media wise uh follow me on Ellen
kimchi spelled with two E's not an eye
cuz I [ __ ] up
okay well check this out if you guys
don't know Ellen is you know just like
one of the hottest choreographers out
there you know I'm saying just killing
it out of the same profession why she's
a dancer but I wanted to bring her to
talk about some other things aside from
Dance I mean we have she could come in
again and talk about a career and then
the whole dance situation remember guys
genius brains yes is out in all all
audio platforms we're talking about
iTunes Spotify whatever podcast hit us
up let us know what's going on
give us that five-star leave comments
below you know situation that you guys
been through things you guys wanna
connect with we have a community here so
just talk back and forth and yeah man
we'll see y'all next time man if you're
sucking dick out there try to do it a
little less unless you enjoyed too much
and if you like getting [ __ ] in the
ass well tell me what you like you
couldn't even just end it nice dude
open my eyes let me see peace out guys